Salut ! Aujourd’hui je vous donne une nouvelle énigme,
mais juste avant je vous donne la solution à l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo d'hier, allez la voir pour voir l'énigme d'abord avant d’écouter la réponse.
La réponse c'était la lettre N.
Tout simplement la lettre N.
Parce que N, c'est bien la lettre qui comment le mot "nuit''.
C'est bien la lettre qui finit le mot "matin".
Et on trouve deux fois la lettre N, dans le mot "année".
C'était un peu une énigme, en mode les chiffres et les lettres.
Je pense que vous êtes nombreux à l'avoir trouvé,
je vais regarder le quota de pouces en l'air par rapport au nombre de vues.
Mais je pense que vous êtes nombreux.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on passe tout de suite à la prochaine énigme.
Les 4 dernières énigmes ! On est sur les 4 dernières énigmes de cette série de l'été
et on reprend la chaîne avec le calendrier habituel dans 5 jours.
Cette énigme 29 est une énigme différente.
Je m'en suis rappelé très très très récemment quand j'ai écrit tout ces énigmes là.
C'est une énigme qu'on m'a fait quand j'étais en colo, quand j'étais petit. Je devais avoir entre 6 et 8 ans.
Et elle m'a fait galéré durant des jours et des jours pour trouver. Je comprenais pas.
Je vous la fait:
"Touche touche pas, touche pas touche." Donc qu'est-ce qui touche et pourquoi ?
La question c'est bien: Qu'est-ce qu'il touche et pourquoi ?
Donc je vous la refait:
"Touche touche pas, touche pas touche." Qu'est-ce qui touche et pourquoi ?
En indice, je pourrai aller plus loin. En vous disant que: "Pourquoi touche ?"
Pourquoi touche ? Mental touche, Vlog touche pas.
Donc qu'est-ce qui touche et pourquoi ?
Et je me souviens que ceux qui m'ont fait l'énigme, ils me faisaient tourner en bourrique,
à me donner des nouveaux mots, à m'expliquer que... que "canapé" ça touche.
Alors que "fenêtre", ça touche pas.
Quand je vais vous donner la réponse demain, vous allez le faire à tout le monde
et vous allez voir, c'est vraiment très drôle à faire.
Mais peut-être que vous connaissez, ou encore mieux, que vous allez trouver la réponse.
Dans ces cas là, ne le dites pas dans les commentaires, pour laisser les autres chercher.
Mais vous le savez, laissez un pouce en l'air qui nous sert pour cette série d'énigme, de compteur,
pour compter le nombre de personnes qui trouvent la bonne réponse.
Profitez encore du soleil. Demain c'est le week-end, donc je suis sûr que vous allez kiffer.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11h, puisque le week-end c'est 11h.
Ciao !